alors moi ma première question elle va
être sur le joueur que thomas a eu entre
les mains et dont on parle le plus
vincent poirier et c'est par rapport à
ce qui peut nous rappeler le processus
parce que pour pour ceux qui l'ont vu
les premiers entraînements de vincent
poirier
honnêtement celui qui disait lui lui il
a de l'avenir
ben aujourd'hui j'espère qu'il a qu'il a
parié dessus et qui s'est fait de
l'argent mais je pense qu'ils n'étaient
pas nombreux voir l avantage des
conseils qui ne l'a pas fait ah oui ça
c'est clair
donc non le créneau pour expliquer
comment as-tu façonné vincent poirier
comment as-tu rhdp la com com tout
commence à chaque fois par de la
détection
et pour l'anecdote c'était vraiment un
hasard c'était un lendemain match pro où
on avait un joueur qui n'avait pas joué
parce qu'il revenait juste de blessure
et donc ce joueur me sollicite pour
venir faire une séance de tiers parce
qu'il n'avait pas joué et qui devait
revenir vraiment être un entraînement
collectif eu là là là c'est la semaine
d'après et donc je fais ma petite séance
avec lui et comme bon bon mec avait rien
à faire de son dimanche je descends dans
la salle du bas de marcel cerdan pour
voir un petit peu les cadets région
et là il ya l'équipe de bussy saint
georges qui jouent contre nos cadets
région et j'arrive au cours du premier
quart temps je pense et il ya un grand
blanc au milieu de tout ça qui est qui
et pas qu'ils aient pas qui n'est pas
très doué mais qui se bat qui courent à
peu près bien pour un mec de sa taille
et donc je reste tout le match je
regarde le match et à la fin du match je
vais voyager voir le coach de bussy
saint georges et et je lui explique que
son son joueurs m'intéressent j'étais
bien sûr aller voir la feuille de match
avant en espérant que ce soit en
première ou deuxième année kb mais
malheureusement c'est un troisième année
cab et le réflexe combat il est né en
quelle année
mais c'était un dernières années et donc
je vais discuter avec ceux ce coach qui
a été super ouvert a voulu a bien voulu
que je parle aux joueurs et que ça m'a
permis de l'inviter sur un camp qu'on
avait pendant les vacances scolaires
d'après c'était au mois de décembre de
l'inviter à notre camp voilà donc
c'était ma première rencontre avec
vincent
il est venu à notre corps faut savoir
cette année-là en gp square avec
laquelle on arrive à être champion de
france donc on a une équipe plutôt un
bon niveau pour chocolat d'espoir et il
fait donc la semaine de camp avec nous
où il est très très en difficulté on
n'arrive pas à le mettre dans le
collectif il fait que les parties
individuelles et après je rencontre son
père et on décide de l'intégrer tous les
lundis parce qu'il avait énormément de
distance pour revenir et mettez plus
d'une heure et demie à venir et à entrer
chez lui donc vu que le mardi matin et
commencer à 10h bon je vous passe les
détails
ils venaient tous les lundis soir une
séance on faisait que du travail de
fondamentaux individuels et les vacances
scolaires on lui faisait ni se passe
dans l'hébergement pour qu'il puisse
puisse être avec nous donc voilà ça
c'est sa première année avec nous sa
première demie année on va dire où il
jouait toujours au club de bussy saint
georges et il avait quand ils arrivent
avec nous ils avaient trois mois de
basket parce qu'il venait juste de
commencer le basket c'est ça c'est ce
qui est important à dire c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui a commencé le basket sur
le tard et justement s comment on
s'adapte à ça surtout quand on est coach
espoir qu on a généralement des gens qui
sont dans les centres de formation ou
coups en tout cas beaucoup d'années de
basket derrière eux déjà cet âge là par
rapport à quelqu'un qu'à trois mois est
ce qu'on entraînement spécifique au delà
de bosser les fondamentaux beaucoup
évidemment à après la facilité pour moi
c'était que j'avais une approche
vraiment basée sur les fondamentaux
c'est à dire que par exemple je faisais
du 5 5
tous les jeudis et un petit peu le
vendredi 28 ans je ferai pas de 5,5 donc
le lundi qui était un entraînement où on
faisait que des fondamentaux par poste
du coup c'était plus facile on va dire
de l'intégrer même s'il était au début
en difficulté c'était plus facile sur
sur les vacances scolaires le matin
c'était que des fondamentaux l'après
midi avait beaucoup de prêts collectif
et après du 5 5
au début ils pouvaient pas jouer dans le
5-5 c'était trop compliqué pour lui mais
il faisait les fondamentaux il dans le 3
3 on arrivait à peut admettre dedans et
après c'était trop trop difficile quoi
comme comme tu l'as dit il avait en face
de lui des joueurs qui en plus ils
avaient des juniors mbida des landing
sané qui étaient dans leur dernière ou
avant dernières années et ce poids et
qui était qui dominait le championnat
espoirs pour un débutant soumettent face
à des mecs qui étaient des bons joueurs
du championnat espoirs c'était compliqué
voilà donc ce c'est là aussi c'est ce
qui m'a donné le plus envie de rentrer
aux stands d'information c'est voir un
garçon qui est en difficulté mais qui
s'accrochaient moi ya des lundis où je
me suis dit la semaine prochaine il
vient pas il s'était fait dunk et dessus
ça causerait dans l'entraînement là ça a
été un centenaire il tombé par terre à
chaque contact parce qu'ils n'étaient
pas prêts physiquement
moi il ya des fois où je me suis dit
c'est fini on l'a perdu c'est trop dur
pour lui et c'est ce qui m'a donné le
plus envie au départ de
de l'intégrer au sein des formations
pour les la saison allait saison d'après
c'était de voir que le gars il revenait
chaque semaine et il essayait quoi il
essayait tomber par terre il se levait
et essayait c'est cette force mentale
qui m'a donné envie de l'intérêt quand
j'ai quand je les rencontre et quand
j'ai revu son père en fin de saison et
lui en disant voilà je veux qu'ils
viennent au centre de formation c'est
vous qui choisissez un deux ou trois ans
annoncé comme vous préférez
mais moi je veux qu'ils rentrent son
information son père venait voir les
matchs le match histoire et venez voir
quelques entraînements il m'a demandé
s'il est sérieux on voulait vraiment
qu'ils rentrent qui prennent la place de
ces mecs là si oui
cc je pense que il fait il faisait de
8,2 de 7 de 8 à l'époque il se déplaçait
déjà plutôt bien il avait fait beaucoup
de foot auparavant donc il avait sur le
travail de pied sur il avait des
facilités il déplaçait plutôt bien donc
voilà on a fait le pari et c'est
vraiment ce qui m'a donné le plus je le
répète ça j'insiste là dessus c'est ça
sa force mentale quoi de dire je restais
j'aurais c'est à chaque fois de se
relever après chaque échec
c'est ça qui m'a donné le plus en vue
d'intégrer mais mes dirigeants après
deux mois de la première saison qui
faisait en complètement demandé de venir
les voir en disant mais qu'est ce que tu
as fait de prendre ce gars là il y aura
jamais non merci
c'est le deuxième détail le plus le plus
important est ce que j'ai une future
section pas ce mot terres désolées
romain mais le souviens toi le fameux la
fameuse histoire des douze minutes
j'espère que tu t'es obligé à le faire
jouer parce qu'effectivement il n'avait
pas le niveau mais et si tu n'avais pas
continuer à obliger entre guillemets à
le faire jouer peut-être qu'il n'aurait
pas eu la même carrière aujourd'hui quoi
parce que ça je sais pas si je peux pas
le savoir
il ya des matches je n'arrivais pas
parce qu'ils et 5 fautes avant de 12
minutes sur le terrain auquel des
matches où je n'arrivais pas mais j'ai
un de mes joueurs espoirs qui comprenait
bien le truc et qui avait déjà eu un
rôle majeur
l'année d'avant qui de temps en temps
quand je les mettais en 2ème mi temps
ils me regardaient en désormais à quoi
tu joues quoi et après moi en tant que
coach d'une équipe espoir si j'intègre
quelqu'un dans mon centre de formation
surtout un grand gabarit il faut qu'ils
jouent
s'ils jouent pas du tout c'est compliqué
parce qu'après on n'avait pas d'autre
autre moyen de le faire jouer parce que
si je l'avais envoyé il ya des joueurs
que j'avais envoyé jouer en équipe
nationale 3 en équipe on avait une autre
équipe régionale et des fois on faisait
jouer des joueurs de l'équipe espoirs en
équipe régionale parce que ça leur
donner plus de temps de jeu
l'huile ça aurait été encore pire pour
lui de jouer dans ce championnat par
rapport au fait qu'il aurait joué des
intérieurs d'un mètre 95 et sarah était
encore plus difficile pour lui donc
viendra dessus tu viens de résumer un
des problèmes de la formation française
sur championne espoir oui oui mais
problème une des solutions parce que
parce que quelque part enfin moi je
reviens sur cette terre il ya deux
choses pour qu'on y vit toujours là de
la taille d'une part ça s'apprend pas
mais la détermination non plus à dire
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut qu'on
peut favoriser dans le travail mais qui
est toujours présente chez les gens de
manière intrinsèque est une manière
naturelle si si on l'a pas au départ
c'est très très dur à développer et
après douala ce que tu dis c'est prendre
le risque à certains moments on quitte à
faire là quitte à les faire le con
trophée du futur ou pas ou quoi que ce
soit de peut-être mettre quelques matchs
en danger pour développer un lien plutôt
que de faire jouer comme je dis souvent
les barbus d'un mètre 95 qui joue poste
5 bon face à aucun intérêt en espoirs et
je trouve ça je trouve ça intéressant de
de faire cette démarche là parce que je
pense que même aujourd'hui j'ai vu
énormément de matches espoirs ces deux
dernières années je pense qu'il ya très
peu de tes collègues du championnat
qu'aurait cette démarche là dans un dans
un but de dans un but de développement
parce qu'on est dans du clonage on a
déjà parlé la dernière fois puis il ya
d'autres auparavant du clonage de ce qui
se fait au niveau et le problème c'est
que le joueur doit être au centre du
projet et c'est trop souvent pas le cas
là ce que tu as fait c'est exactement
cette démarche là ouais ouais après
c'est moi je pense qu'il faut je passe
mitigés mais je pense qu'il faut gagner
les matches par exemple sur la première
année vincent et jouez pas les derniers
cartons parce qu'à un moment donné entre
pareil toute la semaine
il faut apprendre les mecs aussi à
gagner des matchs les cancans je si
quand on va signer un joueur dans une
équipe pro s'il prend 40 points tous les
week-ends dans l'espoir on va dire s'il
a de même pas son équipe espoirs a gagné
comment il va faire pour aider mon
équipe à gagner
voilà donc moi j'avais j'avais cette
limite de dire il faut qu'ils jouent au
moins douze minutes parce que ça quand
même un temps où on peut s'exprimer on
peut faire des erreurs on peut voir là
c'était impossible pour moi de mettre un
garçon quand vincent c'était normal
qu'ils sont en difficulté
je vais le chercher il joue en cadet de
même pas un an de basket
qu'ils soient au niveau de championnat
espoirs c'était impossible donc je le
savais donc fallait pas être surpris par
quelque chose que j'avais déjà
connaissance
donc ils allaient être en difficulté
mais fallait il laisser un espace
d'expression faire des erreurs se
tromper recommencer et en même temps
j'ai essayé de préserver aussi mes
joueurs qui étaient un peu plus mature
et qui eux étaient dans un fin de cursus
espoirs qui voulait gagner des matches
qui voulait aller au trophée du futur
d'ailleurs cette année là on qualifie au
trophée du futur sur l'avant-dernière
journée je crois ont fini septièmes
famille est 7e parce que le c'était une
équipe n'était pas dans le top six têtes
qui était qui était qui était
l'organisatrice du trophée mais ce
dernier quart temps il n'avait pas de
rôle à ce moment là parce que là un
quart temps on s'est accroché on
s'arrachait pour aller gagner le match
pour la 7ème à ma philosophie
à ce moment là mais mais encore une fois
il me donnait envie de le faire jouer
parce qu'un mec comme qui s'entraînait
tous les jours dur qui essayait qui
était à l'ecoute c'était son envie de le
mettre sur un terrain il se la racontait
pas et on voyait qu'il aimait bien le
jeu on l'a envoyé qu'il est qu'il aimait
la compétition et jeudi me donner envie
de le maître sankara simplement un
automate pour les les auditeurs qui
serait pas forcément on va dire
spécialistes même de des entraînements
qu'on peut avoir dans une équipe de
basket de ce niveau là qu'est ce que tu
lui as pris vraiment que tu parlais de
fondamentaux par poste le lundi et ses
caisses que qu'est ce que tu lui as
appris qu'ils savaient pas faire en
arrivant dans ce centre est la première
chose c'est de ces essayer de trouver
quelques un moyen de de le rendre un
minimum efficace sur ce quelques
séquences parce que si le mec est en
échec surtout un moment donné c'est
difficile et la première chose qu'on a
fait c'est capable d'attraper le ballon
de le garder au dessus de sa tête et
d'aller sans dribbler juste attrapé le
ballon sans faire de marché et être
capable avec un petit ou comment droite
de mettre un panier
voilà donc les premiers détails c'était
tu mets un écran tu roules le plus tôt
possible au cercle
tu es capable de t'arrêter et de mettre
un petit panier avec ta main droite avec
ta main gauche
mais après l avantage des mecs ou qui
sont débutants comme lui qu'on pas des
mauvaises habitudes
c'est quand on lui apprend ajouté il
corrige tout très vite parce que il n'a
pas enregistré un mauvais mouvement donc
60 shoot mi-distance
son look dès demain il n'avait pas joué
on va dire 5 ans sur des sur des plus
grands ou dans les clubs où il n'y avait
pas d'entraîneur qui le qui le guidait
vraiment donc il n'avait pas enregistré
un mauvais mouvement dans sa salle cela
peut paraître un handicap dès fois
d'avoir un mec qu'a pas de l'année de
basket derrière lui mais sur certaines
sur certains domaines comme celui là
c'est plutôt un avantage parce qu'il
n'ya pas de mauvais mauvais schéma
motors avait construit en sus exactement
exactement donc lui c'était voilà
c'était une éponge il était à l'écouté
on lui disait de mettre le coup de comm
ca de finir bien cassé le poignet il
tout de suite il essayait tutin essayé
et et après s'il ya des différences
aussi dans la capacité d'apprentissage
et dans dans le niveau intellectuel des
gammes en hausse il faut pas se mentir
qui fait que celui ça allait vite quoi
c'était une éponge
c'était une éponge ça allait vite
d'autres cette année là j'avais un autre
joueur qui avait levé un peu plus de
basket que lui qui était deux fois plus
fort que lui au début de l'année ben la
fin de l'année à la fin de l'année ils
étaient moins bons plus quoi
il ya aussi une histoire c'est
d'ailleurs ce que toi tu as vu quand tu
l'a repéré c'est ce qu'on appelle enfin
tu l'as vu aussi après mais les
américains disent int angie belge sera
pas comment traduire ça en français mais
c'est des choses voilà qui sont innées
en fait la part d'inné c'était c'était
chez lui ce que tu a rappelé c'est quoi
la taille et la coordination et ensuite
plus tard tu as vu la détermination
c'est ça le premier truc c'est sûr c'est
la taille va pas se raconter d'histoires
et il aurait fait 10 centimètres de moi
j'aurais regardé un bout du quart temps
surtout pour voir les jeunes de
levallois et je serais parti alors faut
pas se mentir
donc la taille c'est un critère très
important pour le basket et c1 comme
roman la vie twitter c'est un des
critères où nous les coaches peut rien
faire ou personnes pour rien donc donc
voilà après oui ce qui m'a donné le plus
envie c'est c'est cet acharnement qui
l'avait dans le travail et cette volonté
il a vraiment montré des des capacités
mentales au dessus de la moyenne
c'est clair
et donc ensuite dans les années après
c'est à dire une fois qu'ils commencent
à acquérir les fondamentaux sur voilà
les premières phases où ils arrivent à
être efficace sur des choses assez
simples
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important de
développer au plus vite pour un joueur
avec ce potentiel là donc gros gros
physique
un grosse coordination et c'est que toi
tu t'es attaché à développer chez lui
des cas au niveau basket après on allait
chercher être capable de recevoir la
balle face au cercle faire des passes de
transfert faire des passes nos relations
poste au poste bas
voilà qu'on puisse l'intégrer un petit
peu plus dans le jeu que juste je roule
au cercle attrape la balle près du
cercle
après on allait chercher sur un petit
peu de travail poster qui est pas encore
aujourd'hui sa spécialité même s'il a
progressé
c'est quelque chose qui est pour les
grands gabarits comme lui qui est
difficile souvent les meilleurs pivots
cost bas soit un peu plus on va dire
large et des fois son intégralité un
petit peu plus bas
voilà donc c'est ça ce qu'on allait
chercher
il a un shoot mi-distance et il avait
déjà un show une distance très correct
même si c'est quelque chose auquel ils
travaillent encore beaucoup et qu'il
peut encore progresser là dessus parce
que c'est un jeu sur lequel le shoei
distance me protéger on peut progresser
pardon très très tard encore et il a une
capacité de 2 pasquet intéressante
aujourd'hui points un big men alors à ce
moment là c'était plus compliqué mais on
essayait de le faire participer un petit
peu au jeu pas que en finisseur voilà ça
c'est venu beaucoup plus la deuxième
année parce que la première année mais
bon il m'aurait perdu tous les ballons
et ça aurait pas ça n'aurait pas aidé
mais la deuxième année on allait
chercher un petit peu plus ça après il
ya un point non j'ai pas encore parlé et
qui a été qui a été déterminant c'est
son évolution physique que la première
année à chaque contact qui tombait par
terre
même si l'on va dire le travail de pieds
étaient très correctes et avait pas de
gainage il y avait des gros problèmes de
déplacements latéraux voilà et le
travail le préparateur physique qui avec
avec qui j'ai travaillé à l'époque
s'appelle alexandre kauffmann qui
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le préparateur
physique de l'équipe professionnelle de
boulogne levallois
qui est qui travaillent avec moi sont
des formations du paris levallois à
l'époque a fait un gros gros boulot avec
lui et entre la première saison complète
qui l'avait fait avec nous la deuxième
il avait eu un programme de gainage de
renforcement beaucoup de travail à poids
de corps quand il est revenu au mois
d'août c'est pas tout à fait le même
il avait vraiment suivi ce programme et
il avait travaillé
voilà donc ça a été aussi un des
éléments parce qu'il y avait des progrès
basket qui était pas qu'ils n'étaient
pas utilisables tant que physiquement il
contrôlait pas ses déplacements il
n'arrivait pas à rouler vite et à
s'arrêter
bon voilà je n'arrivais pas à résister
un petit contact donc cette progression
physique l'a aidé à valider on va dire
les progrès basket qu'il avait pu avoir
dans cette première année
c'est assez difficile à croire
aujourd'hui qu'il avait du mal à
résister au contact
quand on quand on connaît évidemment de
l'animal il ya un sujet que je voulais
aborder avec toi c'est un peu un petit
peu en lien finalement puisque à cette
époque là donc été au centre de
formation ensuite a été coach comme
comment on gère cette transition des
romans en a touché un mot tout à l'heure
mais de désespoir vers les pros que ce
soit d'un côté ou de l'autre que tu as
été des deux côtés comment on communique
entre les coaches pour dire voilà tel
joueur on va lui donner un petit peu de
temps de jeu on va essayer de le faire
jouer un petit peu et c'est comment
comment on crée ça en fait passer
pendant la proche est complètement
différente
il ya d'un côté où on nous demande juste
de gagner des matches surtout surtout
chez nous on va dire et d'un autre côté
où on est là pour dire bon le joueur est
arrivé qu'à tel niveau au mois d'août
il va au mois de juin avoir un niveau
largement supérieur
voilà c'est ça notre travail donc
l'approché différente
après il ya le vrai souci qu'on a
aujourd'hui en france c'est que on dit
faire jouer et faire jouer les jeunes
mais y'a aucun coach qui est mieux payés
ou qu'ils gagnent et ou qui a il va
avoir une grande carrière parce qu'il
fait jouer des jeunes en france il ya
des pays où c'est vraiment valorisé oui
où les coaches qui lancent des jeunes
c'est bien de gagner des matches c'est
très bien mais c'est sur le cv c'est
super d'avoir mis sur le terrain tels
joueurs tels joueurs c'est vraiment sur
un câble de visite c'est quelque chose
qui est pris en compte
en france par exemple dans quel pays en
europe de l'est c'est quelque chose les
mails et les coachs d'europe de l'est se
met voilà c'est lui qui a lancé audio
gacé lui qui a lancé ben là c'est
quelque chose qui est qui et dont les
coaches la parlent entre eux en france
on connaît vincent collet parce que il a
coaché l'équipe de france parce qu'il
était champion de france voilà mais on
oublie qu'il a lancé plein plein de
joueurs et je prends devant son collègue
ce que c'est plus connue des coachs mais
elle a d'autres où c'est pareil où il ya
des coachs qui ont qui ont des bons
résultats sportifs et qu'ils aient
jamais lancé un jeune de leurs vices
c'est pas un point négatif pour on va
dire un président français ou pour le
microcosmos d'une micro tendu
l'homme ne me lance pas sûr sur ligne
sur ce truc là lui sur l'image du basket
français à l'étranger se se lance pas
mais c'est moi moi pourra pour essayer
d'ouvrir un petit peu mes horizons et
leur compte et tous deux coaches
étrangers
j'ai fait ça les g7 romain voilà
maintenant non pas on passe pour des
clowns on passe pour des clowns
clairement parce qu'on pense être les
plus forts sur la formation les plus
fort sill plus fort sur ça le problème
c'est que moi je les ai vécus ça fait
huit ans que sur les équipes de france à
l'être à cordes quand on arrive sur les
compètes tout le monde veut nous battre
parce qu'on fait n'importe quoi à leurs
yeux on fait n'importe quoi que le
matériel qu'on a
de manière générale je parle pas en
équipe de france parce qu'on a plus de
moyens que tout le monde parce que si
parce que ça et puis parce que quelque
part on est pas on n'est pas assez
ouverts les côtes français nous on n'est
pas assez ouverts à l'extérieur ce qu'on
pense qu'on est meilleur que tout le
monde donc c'est très compliqué c'est si
tu veux quand j'étais coach espoirs des
fois je me disais un coach pro il
pourrait quand même donné quelques
minutes à des jeunes que j'ai eus je me
rappelle très bien que j'avais eu de
cette frustration au moins avec giovanni
oniangué à levallois qui au début il se
faisait une petite place dans l'équipe
pro et des fois je pensais que le coach
gros il pouvait lui donner quelques
minutes de plus mais quand quand tu
passes à ses autorités
oh c'est la difficulté c'est difficile
aujourd'hui il faut aussi que les causes
sont deux formations se remettre en
cause en disant il faut que je rende mon
joueur efficace pas surtout parce que
c'est impossible que le mec il arrive il
démarre une équipe pro et c'est le
meilleur joueur de l'équipe c'est lui
qui va avoir les ballons décidé je crois
pas où ces quelques phénomènes c'est un
evan fournier peut-être mais mais mais
c'était trop croire mais qui soit
efficace défensivement qui perdent pas
de ballons qui comprennent le jeu et
qu'ils puissent aider une équipe à
gagner des matchs parce que faire jouer
des jeunes juste pour dire ah j'ai fait
jouer des jeunes
je vous dis en france n'a aucun mal à
faire aucun intérêt je fais jouer un
jeune parce que je sais que
défensivement sur ce poste-là il est
solide
je sais que il comprend le jeu et qui va
faire les extras passe quand il faut
faire les extras pas ce qui peut mettre
un tiers quand il est tout seul
voilà je fais jouer le jeune parce
qu'ils m'aident à gagner des matches
tout simplement cessé aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est ce que tout le monde
doit aller tous les coachs sont deux
formations qui peuvent être frustrés
tentant de comprendre et c'est plus
facile de dire ah le coach qu il fait
pas chaud les jeunes que dire
mince j'ai loupé ça il manque il manque
ça à mon joueur pour que le coach pro
puisque mettre sur le terrain
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut plus qu
en penser comme ça c'est très
intéressant
est ce que tu peux nous parler qu'est ce
que tu as fait en fait c'est malik des
clippers
concrètement gt gt invité par l'équipe
heures ça allait suivre pendant la
summer league
donc j'ai découvert un autre univers que
je connaissais pas ce que j'avais jamais
été au contact comme ça d'une structure
aussi si imposante on va dire qu'une
équipe nba
donc j'ai eu la chance de passer le
trendy campe avec eux et le début de la
semaine en ligue avec eux à las vegas
donc c'était très intéressant on était
14 d'assistant coach
donc quand on sait qu'en france il ya
des clubs qui grincent des dents quand
la ligue veut imposer un deuxième
assistant coach obligatoire en jeep est
dit on était 14e temps coach alors pour
le coup j'ai trouvé que c'était trop
parce que du coup tous les rôles étaient
pas forcément tout le temps superman est
finie et entend y avait des gens qui se
marche un peu sur les pieds mais mais
c'était intéressant de voir une autre
façon de travailler je suis pas je ne
suis pas avoir vu deux des états unis en
disant on est nuls enfants en france on
connait rien au basket j'ai réappris le
basket pas du tout par contre dans la
façon de travailler dans le fait qu'ils
et de multiples intervenants au cours de
l'entraînement ce qui fait que quand on
finit aux 5,5 et le coach prend la
parole
savoie les 9 pour la journée aïe c'est
pas lui qui a fait l'échauffement ce
n'est pas lui qui a fait promettra
exercice défensif le premier essai de
contre attaque et il arrive on va dire
sur la forme d'entraînement et les
joueurs sont pas là c'est de savoir
voilà c'est des choses que j'ai trouvé
très intéressante et surtout les changes
avec avec les coachs et ai été vraiment
vraiment vraiment bien quand je suis
revenu avec plein d'idées pour la façon
d'entraîner plus que plein de nouvelles
idées sur le basket je suis venu avec
des nouvelles idées sur la fonction
d'entraîneur
tu peux développer un peu là-dessus
justement c'est sans trahir des secrets
qd tu voudras incarnant il n'y a pas de
secret de toutes façons c'est très
simple c'est un seul entraînement par
jour
entraînement assez long nous devient
l'ennemi
voilà je n'ai jamais beaucoup plus mais
avant la salle est ouverte d'une heure
avant les joueurs arrivent entre 45
minutes et une heure avant
l'entraînement et avant il ya des
jacinthes et un des coachs pour les
faire shooter des préparateurs physiques
pour laure aider à faire quelques
exercices destinés pour soigner pour les
préparer à bien s'entraîner pour faire
des soins voilà et après il ya deux
heures et demie d'entraînement collectif
qui est minuté voilà un réunion des
coachs avant est vraiment très précises
la minute et où pendant ces deux heures
et demie ils vont avoir
il va voir si cette cause différents qui
vont mener un exercice qui vont mener
une situation avec chez nous en tout cas
couach et aux clippers ça se finissait
par le coach qui gérait le cinq contre
cinq
voilà et puis à la fin s'ils veulent
travailler mais il ya des coachs encore
pour les faire tirer il ya encore après
par les préparateurs physiques qui sont
là et encore les kinés qui sont là voilà
c'est juste les moyens financiers sont
tellement important qu'on peut se
permettre des ils peuvent se permettre
des choses qu'on peut pas faire en
france mais j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant
les mecs après il est tranquille l'après
midi il restait un gros de 8h30 à 9h à
14h30 à la salle y manger avant de
partir et puis après ils étaient
tranquilles voilà plutôt que faire le
fameux 10 heures 17 heures entraînement
come on come on fait beaucoup en france
il avait recoupé ça sur un seul moment
ce qui permettait aussi de donner toute
l'après-midi d'arrière de récupération
et que les joueurs soient aussi un peu
plus frais le lendemain matin
donc j'ai trouvé ça intéressant il faut
il faut du staff faire pour vraiment
être être qu'on peut faire ça bien il
faut du staff mais ça ça m'a donné des
idées simples c'est intéressant et moi
j'ai eu la chance l'an dernier de passer
trois jours dans le dans la masia de
barcelone est en fait ce que tu décris
là c'est exactement la journée type d'un
jeune académicien du barça avec avec un
luxe que on ne peut pas avoir pour
l'instant en france c'est un coach pour
trois joueurs
mais là c'était là il y avait plus de
gauche que le joueur d'accord encore
mieux alors tu ne s'est peut-être pas
mais un de nos chouchous quand même
l'année dernière chez envergure
s'appelle fiona du kabengele oui et donc
ils étaient dans leur os l'amérique des
clippers qui a été puisqu'il a été
drafté par les clippers
enfin par les net's mais transfère aux
clippers pour mémoire le pic 27 de
l'année dernière qu'est ce que tu penses
de son potentiel toi qui l'a côtoyé de
près
il a déjà physiquement il n'est pas très
grand pour on va dire pour son poste de
jeu par contre il a une mobilité un
rapport aux mobilités puissance qui est
clair hors du commun
il est vraiment intéressant
moi j'ai eu et entre unis mais une
relation petit peu particulier parce qu
amplifier par le français donc du coup
je les brancher un peu en français au
début parce que je savais qu'ils étaient
d'origine congolaise donc gelé quelques
congolais par la france est donc de les
brancher un petit peu en français au
début il ya de suite répondu donc
c'était très sympa non
j'espère qu'il va avoir du temps de jeu
parce que maintenant ils ont une grosse
grosse équipe qui va avoir du temps de
jeu aux canons s'exprimer mais il a un
coeur énorme
il se bat sur chaque ballon au rebond il
est vraiment impressionnant et voilà moi
ce qui m'a plus impressionné c'est son
rapport mobilité par rapport à la
puissance physique qui dégage il était
hors du commun
il a un vrai shoot mi-distance il faut
jeter un petit peu à trois points il
anguille l'encourager je pense que c'est
vraiment un axe sur lequel ils veulent
développer tout un trois points pour
pouvoir le faire passer vraiment sur le
poste 4 qui aujourd'hui où il jouait
plus comme 1,5 à l'université mais voilà
c'est un joueur qui me paraît avoir un
profil très intéressant pour toi c'est
plus intéressant pour toi c'est ce sera
un poste 4 s'il fait une vraie carrière
nba ce sera au poste 4 honnêtement je
suis passé expert de la nba pour dire
aux petits pour être poste au sein
canebiers moi aujourd'hui il vient il
vient orléans view c'est mon pivot
titulaire et je pense qu'il peut
vraiment faire mal au poste 5 ans en
jeep ai dit voilà parce que je me sens
plus prêt alloué cinq cas jouer 4 mai
mais sur l'envié je suis passé expert de
la nba pondère éléctro coaching arrivera
pas on est bien on aime bien parler de
l'état d'esprit nous aussi le côté
mental
les évaluations mentale et toi tu as
senti qu'il avait cette éthique de
travail dont tu parles avec vincent
poirier à propos de vincent poirier
cette détermination qui a senti qu'il
avait ouais ouais j'ai senti vraiment
les gens des clippers était très heureux
de
de son recrutement et ils disent qu'ils
disaient tous à c'est un super mec c'est
un guerrier
c'est un mec temps rine bosser et bah
quand je les ai vu de mes yeux c'était
vrai voilà c'est un des premiers arrivés
à l'entraînement il avait toujours envie
de faire un peu plus un peu plus de
shoots à la fin parce que justement ce
quelque chose qui veut développer ses
projets du club de la franchise mais
c'est aussi son projet personnel donc
forcément ça marche mieux quoi ces jeux
j'espère que ça va être une belle saison
pour lui ok et ben écoute romain en moi
sur kabengele dans le wagon longtemps
parisot draft et terrance man aussi que
moi personnellement j'adore dans mon
style du second tour
donc je sais pas si tu l'as vu évolué
aussi l'été dans quoi ils étaient là et
et il avait déjà le projet parce qu'il a
fait il a joué un peu même erreur et dès
le début de la delà de la summer league
ils ont eu ce projet de le mettre un
petit peu je pense est l idée de doc
rivers de mettre un petit peu à la mène
et je me rappelle que le premier
entraînement il avait pas trop fait et
que dès le deuxième entraînement il faut
qu'on fasse jouer un petit peu meilleure
en gros c'était une commande de doc
rivers
donc ils l'ont fait je meurs et pour
être très franc
après la première journée quand ils
m'ont dit il faut ils vont faire le
meneur est quand même ça pas là du tout
d'être un meneur
c'est pas ça me paraît bizarre et il
s'est bien débrouillé et j'ai pour le
coup j'avais pas vu ça moi sur la
première journée 2 avec lui deux camps
et il a montré des choses vraiment
intéressantes à la mène que ce soit sur
les entraînements suivants ou sur les
matchs sont au rendez-vous il a été
utilisé à ce poste
absolument il signe avec jugé plus les
stades de summer league en tête mais
effectivement belle efficacité dans
l'organisation du jeu et puis présence
dans tous les secteurs parce que les
grands vraiment une capacité à prendre
des robots pour genre extérieur puis ils
défendent il est intense
c'est vraiment un garçon aussi
intéressant a su très bien et bien
écoute je te remercie beaucoup de ce
retour d'expérience aux clippers
évidemment surtout en france on le
souhaite
souhaite le maintien du coup le maintien
chez sera possible c'est ça pour pouvoir
le travail et le mieux possible pour la
saison prochaine